February is filled with excitement from
the big game to Valentine's Day and
there is no better place to be for those
events than the Mirage we have the
general manager of nightlife Brent marks
and executive chef David glass here
joining us thank you guys for being here
thank you for having us I am so excited
about what you guys have going on at the
Mirage I mean whether it is the big game
or Valentine's Day you've got some great
packages Chef can you tell us a little
bit about what you have going on yep
football fans love the Mirage uh for the
big game we really go all out and um so
we've got a package in our sports book
coming up on the big game which will be
250 all inclusive for beverage we've got
stadium seating three to four seat
couches and all the food that you want
to order
lots of big game-centric type of food
that is a deal if you think about it
with the food and the drink and then a
place to sit I mean what a place and the
food the food let's talk a little bit
about some of the food yeah so at Mirage
we actually activate a lot of our
different outlets and we've got kind of
one of each from a few of the different
Outlets that we that we're featuring
here
um so starting with at the sports book
we have a foot long hot dog again
there's all kinds of yeah
there's there's it's a classic and as is
the menu in the sports book it's it's
really a bunch of the Classics for
chicken wings chicken tenders french
fries all of those that you know people
are gonna love
um and then you know at rum bar which is
recently remodeled we've we've done a
lot in there there's indoor and outdoor
seating with
um space heaters and fire pits and it's
great indoor and outdoor it's a stone's
throw away from the strip but even if
you lose your bet don't throw any stones
don't talk about some of the drinks too
because they're plenty and you're going
to make one for us too Brent and let's
let's get into the Valentine's Day Motif
here yeah so we really wanted to elevate
the property especially with Valentine's
Day coming up so I mean if you think
about it like an intimate date you could
start at our Lobby Bar then go to one of
our great restaurants like our
Steakhouse Heritage our Japanese
restaurant Otoro or if you want
something more Italian we have a
restaurant called Osteria Costa I've
been there that place is so good yeah I
mean all the restaurants are so good
yeah exactly and then after you can
catch live music and then or if you want
more of a club Vibe you can go to rumbar
um or just the show we have like the
love Beetle show as well and you can get
these cocktails at all of them okay
let's make one really quick you're gonna
you guys have a lot of specialty ones
it's so beautiful so we have Cupid's
kiss Bella and our chocolate martini and
then this one that we're featuring is
our pop rock and drop it oh Pop Rocks in
there yes that's so that's the rim so
basically it's a raspberry peach and
lime and then when you take a sip from
the rim it's like a burst of Valentine's
Day love oh that's beautiful I mean this
whole setup now if people want more
information on the celebrations whether
it's the big game or Valentine's Day how
do they get information to buy tickets
and all that Hard Rock Hotel Casino Las
Vegas or you can dial our concierge
702-791-711 that is absolutely delicious
and again these packages are unheard of
of four-seater couches for 250 dollars
per person and again that's with the
food all-inclusive beverage food food is
a la carte okay but that's fine the
beverage is what I'm thinking like wow
so make sure you check it out the Mirage
again they are operating now by the Hard
Rock Hotel so you can get more
information at Hard Rock Hotel Casino
Las vegas.com